[MUSIC PLAYING]
JON FOUST: Hi, and
welcome to Episode 198
of the weekly "Google
Cloud Platform" podcast.
I am Jon, and I'm here
with my colleague, Gabi.
Hey, Gabi.
How's it going?
GABI FERRARA: Hello, Jon.
How are you?
JON FOUST: I'm doing great.
How about yourself?
GABI FERRARA: I'm good.
JON FOUST: So this week,
our guest is Laura Ham.
She's a solution community
engineer at SeMI Technologies.
And she's working on a
project called Weaviate, which
is going to be very amazing.
They deal with knowledge
graphs, and we're
going to have a very interesting
conversation because both Gabi
and I are both interested
in knowledge graphs.
GABI FERRARA: Yeah,
database things, also.
It's nice.
So it's not a
database, but it kind
of stores relationships
and data and how
they relate to each other.
So it's kind of nice.
I'm going to learn about that.
JON FOUST: Yeah, I think we
talked about it at Cloud Next
with one of our guests who
stopped by in the booth.
GABI FERRARA: Yeah.
JON FOUST: And we were talking
about how we can use it
in games, if I remember.
GABI FERRARA: Yeah, it was
David Allen from Neo4j.
It's nice.
JON FOUST: And we will
also get into our question
of the week is, when will Python
be reaching its end of life?
So sad.
And what does it mean for GCP?
But before that, let's get into
our cool things of the week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GABI FERRARA: OK.
We're going to see
on the show notes now
one example of how to use
G Suite to make documents
and other tools more accessible
to people with disabilities.
Not just for people with visual
impairment or other kinds
of physical impairments,
but also stuff like I
learned today about
visual crowding,
which means you can't see
phones in a certain way.
So they are the different
kind of phones and typography,
so you can be able to do that.
And one of the things also
is the visual screen reader
technology that they improved.
So check out on the show
notes to see more about that.
JON FOUST: That's awesome.
Going through college, I was
a computer engineering major,
so I was building
circuits and building
actual physical devices.
And it was pretty
fun to do that.
But my focus was
mainly on helping those
with disabilities.
And it was really great to
see the shift towards using
technology to do so.
GABI FERRARA: Oh, yeah,
as an able person,
as they say, they usually
distinct us like that,
we should be [INAUDIBLE]
accessibility
not just like on this, but
on everything that we do.
JON FOUST: Right.
The next thing we
have on our agenda is,
there's a blog post that's
written on the Google Cloud
Blog about four steps to
stop data exfiltration
with the Google Cloud.
So if you're not familiar
with Cloud DLP, or Data Loss
Prevention, it's a way
to understand and manage
your sensitive data and PII.
And what it does is allows
you to pretty much redact
information like credit
cards, names, Social Security
numbers, and all other
personal information.
And it's very fast
and very scalable.
And when you deal with that and
it stores all this information
in Cloud Buckets--
or it scans Cloud
Buckets, actually--
it helps you stay in compliance
with regulations and keeping
PII safe.
And you can then use Cloud
SCC or Cloud Security Command
Center, to actually
then manage and store
all of this information.
So if you're really interested
in keeping your data safe,
I suggest you check it out.
GABI FERRARA: Is scanning
the buckets this important?
I don't want my credit
card numbers on there.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, talking about Python,
there is a Colab Notebook,
how to know how the weather is.
Using Colab and BigQuery,
you do a weather analysis.
And there is this
cool thing on Colab,
which are interactive tables.
So you don't need to
list all results at once.
You can scroll through
the tables, for instance.
And it mixes out Python
and SQL, of course.
[LAUGHTER]
And check it out.
So you can do weather
line analysis.
And I think it's from
the past years in there.
So you can kind of predict
what's coming, which is nice.
JON FOUST: I was just
out this weekend.
And there was no
forecast of rain.
But--
[RAINING]
--sure enough, as
soon as I stepped out
of the train station,
it just started
having a little drizzle.
And I did not prepare for that.
So hopefully, we can really get
weather down to a, you know,
exact--
[LAUGHS]
--science, and hopefully, I
won't be wet on my way home.
And to round things off for
our cool things of the week,
there are updates to AutoML
Vision Edge, AutoML Video,
and AutoML Intelligence APIs.
So in April, AutoML
Vision Edge was announced.
And it was pretty much
created to help business train
and deploy ML
models on the Edge.
And now, we have AutoML
Video and AutoML Intelligence
to join the party.
So just to give you an idea
of what AutoML Edge does
is, if you check
out the blog post,
it's a really interesting
video on one of our customers,
who, you can take a picture
of a engagement ring
and actually use
AR to try it on,
which is really, really cool.
So the actual updates are
being able to detect objects
and logos, videos, and images.
It allows you to then train
your models to handle that.
So it's pretty interesting,
pretty awesome.
And it's going to make
things a lot more fun.
GABI FERRARA: And without
having to code everything
on TensorFlow--
[LAUGHTER]
--which is nice.
Not complaining about
TensorFlow, it just--
I don't have the
knowledge to do that.
JON FOUST: Right.
Whatever makes things easier.
GABI FERRARA: Yeah.
[LAUGHS]
JON FOUST: All right.
So now that we're wrapped
up with our cool things
of the week, let's go chat
with our great friend, Laura,
who is going to be telling us
more about knowledge graphs.
GABI FERRARA: Let's go.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We're here today with Laura Ham.
She's solution community
engineer at SeMI Technologies.
And welcome, Laura.
Tell us what you do and
what your company do.
LAURA HAM: Thanks
for the introduction.
So I'm Laura Ham.
I'm from the Netherlands, but
currently living in Helsinki.
So yes, community solution
engineer at SeMI Technologies--
I build and support a community
around our open source
software, Weaviate.
And I also take care of
the developer and user
experience within the business.
This means that I, for
example, write documentation
to support both
developers and the users.
And I also research and
evaluate new use cases
or new implementations
in the software regarding
user experience.
Yeah, that's what
I do within SeMI.
JON FOUST: Nice.
It sounds like you wear
quite a bit of hats.
You're a community
solution engineer.
So we're almost in similar
roles, where we interact
with developer communities.
And we, you know, we build
solution and documentation.
But you also mentioned that
you are a UX researcher.
So can you tell us
a little bit how
you got into that--
like your background?
And just give our listeners,
you know, a little insight
on how to get into something
like being a community solution
engineer.
LAURA HAM: Yeah, sure.
So I actually started
from the beginning.
So SeMI was a small startup.
I joined in the
beginning as mainly
researching possibilities--
how to build a knowledge graph.
More specifically, I was the
bridge between UX designers, so
who are in direct contact
with potential users of such
an interface, and core
developers of our software,
which means that
I was not really,
like, officially UX
design, but more designing
a good experience for
all the developers.
And then, as we went on--
like, our products got bigger--
we got more people onboard.
And we decided that our products
will always be open source.
So Weaviate will
always be open source.
And we want to build
a community around us,
because we want to
spread these products
and also to help other
people and other people
to help us with developing this.
JON FOUST: Awesome.
We really enjoy people, who are
interacting with communities,
especially in open source,
because it allows developers
to help build out the product
that they truly desire.
And it's always just
great to have people
from all different backgrounds
and all different experiences
come together to
actually build something.
That's amazing.
So thank you, SeMI--
[LAUGHS]
--Technologies for contributing
to the open source community.
[LAUGHTER]
LAURA HAM: Cool.
Of course, I agree.
GABI FERRARA: And you
mentioned Weaviate, right?
LAURA HAM: That's right.
GABI FERRARA: So
for us, what it is--
Weaviate?
LAURA HAM: Yeah, so Weaviate
is a knowledge graph--
open source knowledge
graph, which
enables you to do contextualized
search based on your data
you put in.
More specifically,
we have, instead
of a traditional database,
where data in a database
has no meaning at all--
so a database doesn't know what
kind of knowledge is in there--
we create meanings.
We attach meanings to
the data, which you
put in the knowledge graphs.
This all goes automatically.
And this enables
you to do search
based on this knowledge you
put in to gain more knowledge.
You can get more knowledge
out of it, let's say.
GABI FERRARA: So how
do you query that data?
Like, you put the data there.
It's, like, a knowledge graph.
But how do you retrieve
the data from there?
It's almost like a
graph, right, as I said.
So I know some graph databases.
But I don't think it's a
graph database, per se.
Or is it?
LAURA HAM: It is not a
graph database, per se.
That's right.
The structure is based
on a graph, though.
And we want to have a
big variety of users
being able to use and
query this graph, which
is why I designed a GraphQL API,
which is a way you can almost
use natural language
to query the API, which
is designed by ourselves.
JON FOUST: That sounds amazing.
I'm going to circle back on
the natural language part,
because that's very interesting.
But can you give me
example of a knowledge
graph, because I don't
particularly work in data--
like, a sneak peek of, you know,
someone who's using Weaviate
would use to actually build out?
LAURA HAM: Yeah, sure.
So we can take as an example,
countries and cities.
So if we have the
country, Netherlands,
where I'm from with
the capital Amsterdam,
we have a clear link between
Amsterdam and the Netherlands,
because Amsterdam is the
capital of the Netherlands.
The knowledge graph
stores this data.
It has a link between the
Netherlands and Amsterdam.
And if we, then,
have, for example,
a second country in
there, which is Germany,
and we have a second city
in there, which is Berlin,
but we didn't make the link
yet between Berlin, which
is the capital of Germany,
we can automatically
classify this and make
the link to the capital.
JON FOUST: Sounds like
a knowledge graph, too,
is they-- it starts off
with, I would say, a node,
like many graphs do.
And it seems like once you
want to populate new data,
it just starts to bridge off
into different directions,
almost like building
a map, like,
in this particular example.
And you're starting to
populate different nodes
with more and more information.
And then, from each node,
it seems to spread--
continue to spread, continue
to gather more information.
So but it obviously
can be user defined,
or it can be
automatically done, right?
LAURA HAM: Yeah, that's right.
So data is stored
based on this meaning
instead of based
on nothing or based
on a number, which is in a
relational or traditional
database.
And that's the most
important difference for us.
And then, based on this
meaning, you can make new links
and extract new knowledge.
That's right.
JON FOUST: Awesome.
LAURA HAM: And that's all starts
with the nodes, as you say,
which we define as classes.
So we have a class
country, a class city,
which has certain properties.
Country has a
property has capital.
JON FOUST: And just to circle
back on the natural language
that you've been using, can
you tell us a little bit more
about that?
LAURA HAM: Yeah, so for
the GraphQL API, you mean?
JON FOUST: Yes.
LAURA HAM: Yeah, for our
query language GraphQL,
we wanted to make it usable
for as many people as possible.
So yeah, for example, query
languages like Cypher or Neo4j,
but those are kind
of hard to understand
and not really intuitive if you
see them for the first time.
So what I've done
with GraphQL is
start with how you
would ask a database
or how you would ask
something with data in it
to get back what you
actually are looking for.
So I started from this basis.
And from there, I found that
some keywords were coming back
all the time.
If I can give an
example, so if you
know what you're looking
for, you very often
use the word "get"--
so can I get this
specific thing?
So that is why a very key
function in the GraphQL API
is the get function.
So you start with get.
And then, you go on.
GABI FERRARA: You
mentioned the example
of countries and capitals.
So what is the most common use
case, like, for a business,
like, that people
use it for that?
Like, that example was abstract,
but like, a real-world example
that people are using this.
LAURA HAM: So for example,
if we are going on
on this context-based
search, then
we can look into
scientific articles.
For example, if you have
a database of articles
and you want to look
for a specific topic,
then you might start
looking at some words, which
are not actually
present in this article.
So you might start looking for
some kind of specific disease.
But this disease is named
differently in an article.
And you still want
to find this article.
And if we have all this
data in our knowledge graph,
then you could actually
find articles like this.
So you search based on the
context instead of search
based on the exact keywords.
JON FOUST: OK.
And that is pretty much
defined by each node
in your graph's actual data.
That is either supplied by a
user or built automatically.
LAURA HAM: Yeah, correct.
And the nice thing is is
that you give a structure
to your data yourself.
So that's what we call
an ontology or a schema.
You define your own ontology.
But what happens is
if you put in data,
factors are generated
automatically
to represent the
meaning of these words.
And that is not only
depending your own ontology,
but that is based on what
we call Contextionary, which
is a vector representation
or machine learning
model, which has learned on a
whole Wikipedia in Wiktionary.
So it gives a meaning so that
others can also understand it.
JON FOUST: Awesome.
I'm going to pretend I
know what ontology is.
But for our listeners, can you
give us a hardcore definition
of what ontology is?
LAURA HAM: [LAUGHS] Yeah, sure.
So an ontology is a description
of, well, the meaning
of the words basically.
So how we use ontology is we
define classes and properties.
So as I said earlier, we have a
class, which can be a country.
And you describe
what country means.
And a country can
have properties.
So it can have a capital.
It has a population.
It might be in a
certain region--
whatever you want
to give to that.
And then, you can-- when you
populate your knowledge graph,
your database, and you
want to add a country,
you give the country,
Netherlands, the label Country.
GABI FERRARA: Can
a class reference
another class in the property?
I'm going to give
you an example.
Like, let's say the
UK sends off countries
of their Commonwealth, right?
So let's say you
have a property,
which it is like empire
countries-- whatever--
because that's the--
UK has all the Great Britain
and I think Scotland and Wales.
So it's a country
inside other countries.
Could you do that, too?
LAURA HAM: Yeah, yeah, sure.
So we have two types of
properties a class can have.
One is just some data.
So if you have the population of
a country, it's just a number.
But the example of
city that I gave,
the city is another class.
So you refer to this other
node in the database.
And you can do the same
with other countries.
You can refer to a
same class again.
Yup.
JON FOUST: I'm really, like,
interested in ontology.
I didn't know what it was.
I'm just pretending
for our viewers.
I really enjoyed
that definition,
the meaning of words.
I believe that's what you said.
So I guess to ask a follow-up,
can you give us, like,
a good example of, like, a
pretty, like, basic example
of the meaning of
words, meaning when
you said that, I immediately
went back to my college days
when I took logical classes.
And everything was
pretty much quantitative.
Like, it's universal
or pretty much
like all things that are cute
are dogs, or all dogs are cute.
Or cats are boring, for example.
[LAUGHTER]
[MEOW]
LAURA HAM: Yeah, that's
a very good example,
what you just
mentioned, because it
is-- an ontology is something
everyone defines for itself.
So if we have a bank,
for example, the word
"bank," if I say
"bank," you might think
of a financial institution.
But another might
think of a river bank.
JON FOUST: Oh, OK.
LAURA HAM: So that's why
we define the word "bank"
in ontology with a description.
And that's where it gets a
vector representation, which
represents its meaning.
So we have two banks.
And in a traditional database,
they would mean the same thing.
But for us, we have
two different things.
And then, another good
point is what you said,
is that everyone
defines it differently.
If we can use "bank" again, some
people might say it's a bank.
But some people might say
it's a financial institution.
So people don't speak
the same language.
So that is why in our knowledge
graph, a bank is the same--
like, the financial institution
bank-- is the same thing.
And then, we have
the other-- the river
bank as a separate thing.
So the knowledge graph does make
a difference between those two
words.
JON FOUST: Awesome.
Ontology is based on
many different things.
Like, you know, people may
define banks different ways.
So I have another question.
For ontology, it seems
like it's based on--
I won't say only
environment, but pretty
much everybody's way of living.
So for example, if I were in
the Harry Potter universe--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
--then my ontology of some
things might be different.
For example, like, medicine
might be different in the Harry
Potter universe.
And they might have
different terminology.
But we might share
the same technology
in our non-fantasy world, where
medicine is just a little bit
more practical and scientific.
People are measuring and
testing and everything,
where with Harry
Potter, it's, I'm
going to throw this together.
And if it works, it
works, because you know,
I've tested it once separately.
And together, I believe
that this is the result
that it will have.
It seems like ontology
is based solely
on the actual surroundings
in the environment
and as well as people's
definitions and way of living.
Is that correct?
LAURA HAM: Yeah, that's correct.
[DING]
And that is why everyone
has their own ontology.
I don't know if you
noticed, but people
have been trying to
make a formal ontology
for, for example,
the web in the past.
And people just cannot
agree on a formal ontology,
because everyone's
meaning is different,
because it's based on their
own environment, as you say.
And that's exactly one of the
key points we want to avoid.
So everyone can define
their own ontology
here so that they can
query and ask the knowledge
graph in their own language.
And we solved this
whole problem with,
like, the machine learning model
we built within the knowledge
graph to still be able to make
the links between the thing you
mean and the thing I mean,
which is actually the same.
But we just name it differently.
JON FOUST: Got it.
That's awesome.
GABI FERRARA: So to steer
back a bit that conversation,
your product helps solve a
lot of different problems
that people has, because usually
our common relational database
may not be what
they're looking for,
although I still like them.
And--
[LAUGHTER]
LAURA HAM: That's OK.
GABI FERRARA: Can
you explain to us
how the portfolio
of Google Cloud
helps SeMI to develop
their technology
or to help bridge the gap
that people see that you're
trying to help people with?
LAURA HAM: Yeah,
so first of all,
like, the core of
our knowledge graph
is built on Kubernetes, which
is, of course, a Google Cloud
product.
And then, we have, for example,
Google Weaviate clusters.
Yeah, they act as 10 boxes,
which anyone can request.
And they can try out the
Weaviate for some time.
And we run these clusters on
the Google Cloud, as well.
And then, also, as we are still
highly developing our software,
our whole development
pipeline goes
through Google Cloud, which
is really nice, for example,
is that we use Travis.
And as soon as we commit a new--
an updated version to GitHub,
Travis will start a test, which
all goes through Google Cloud.
So it starts a cluster there.
And it also, like, runs
the tests over there
and shuts it down.
So all in all, it really helps
us in the whole development
process.
GABI FERRARA: Does it help on
the machine learning part, too?
Like, do you use, like,
TensorFlow or something
like that that you mentioned?
LAURA HAM: We didn't use
Google machine learning, yeah,
not TensorFlow or the other--
GABI FERRARA: Yeah, we
have Speech-to-Text and--
LAURA HAM: ML.
[LAUGHS]
GABI FERRARA: --ML
Engine and other stuff.
LAURA HAM: Yeah.
GABI FERRARA: I
was just curious--
LAURA HAM: Yeah.
GABI FERRARA: --because you
mentioned machine learning.
And the first thing that
people think about Google
Cloud-- oh, machine
learning, you know.
No, no--
[LAUGHS]
--no, we're not using it.
LAURA HAM: No, and
in addition, like,
it's not only Google Cloud,
which is helping us a lot,
but also Google, in general,
because we are still
in the startup phase
of the business.
And Google is really helpful.
For example, I went
to I/O one year ago
and met a lot of people there.
It was through
community tickets.
And also with, like,
the podcasts like this,
we are organizing talks.
So that's also a pro for Google.
JON FOUST: You mentioned
that you're still
in the startup phase.
So I would imagine that
there have probably
been some bumps and hurdles
along in your development
process.
How would you say Google
has helped you specifically
on that?
What I mean is,
do we have support
that either comes to you or you
know, is able to help you out?
Or I know that Weaviate
is open source.
So I'm sure that you have
an open source community
that you interact with.
When you get stuck
in development, like,
what is your go-to
method of fixing that?
LAURA HAM: The only
thing that I can
say, because I am
not one of the,
like, let's say, core
developers anymore--
if we get stuck is that we have
some community backups acquired
through Google.
So although they might not be
direct relations to Google,
the network gained through a
Google Meetups, for example.
GABI FERRARA: And
that's a curiosity.
Do you do Weaviate--
you're a startup.
You do open source.
But like, you still have
to pay the bills, right?
So do you offer Weaviate as
a, like, SaaS product, too.
Like, for instance, I don't
want to have to manage this.
I want you to manage
that for me, you know.
Do you do this
kind of work, too?
Or it's like, no,
it's like you need
to install your own
cluster and do everything?
Like, well, how does it work?
LAURA HAM: Yeah, so Weaviate
is, indeed, open source.
And it will always
stay open source.
But what we are doing
at SeMI Technologies
is that we offer
our consulting help
for getting started
with building
a whole Weaviate for companies.
And secondly, because
Weaviate is open source,
it comes with an
open source license.
And for bigger businesses,
we offer Weaviate Enterprise,
which comes with the
liability would go to us.
And that's what we're building
the business about basically.
JON FOUST: Awesome.
We know based on, you
know, for example, like,
the success of Kubernetes,
being open source
and then becoming managed as
GKE, we've seen the success.
So it's great to see that we
are contributing both to open
source, as well as offering
some liability and some support
for, you know, our users.
So it seems like
Weaviate is really making
a lot of strides in that area.
LAURA HAM: If you look at
really popular applications
nowadays, like Uber
and Netflix, it's
built on, like, maybe
100 products, among which
Google Bigtable, MySQL--
all these kind of
services everyone knows.
And our goal, as a
open source product,
is to get in this
list, to get people
working with knowledge graphs.
And that is why one
of our key points
is to remain open source.
JON FOUST: So you just said
something very interesting.
You want to enter into this
space, where Weaviate is
a go-to for knowledge graphs.
But I'm curious.
For your Enterprise solution,
what are these companies
using Weaviate
for, specifically,
because you mentioned Uber?
And I immediately thought,
oh, that's a good use
of potential knowledge
graphs in Uber
or you know, something else.
So I'm just curious, in
your Enterprise Edition,
what are you seeing a lot
of use cases for Weaviate?
LAURA HAM: There are
different possibilities,
because one of the
things we offer
due to our machine learning
model is classification.
So what we can,
for example, do is
in the area of cybersecurity
is classifying emails
if they are potential
threats or contains
phishing or not
based on the context
of the email and the knowledge,
which is already in your graph.
And secondly, as
an Enterprise, you
can gain knowledge out of your
data that you already have.
So if you have a lot of
customer data, for example,
the knowledge graph
may be able to make
new links between things
you hadn't thought about.
And then, you're like, aha.
Maybe this is a new
business case for us.
JON FOUST: OK.
So the machine learning
aspect of Weaviate
is actually like a
churn model, where
it's pretty much identifying
different and new
potential business aspects.
So Weaviate essentially
is just trying
to connect your customers to
more areas of your business.
And I'm assuming that in other
use cases or other companies,
it seems like it would
be connecting users
to your product a lot better.
[LAUGHS]
LAURA HAM: Yeah, as Weaviate,
we stop also, because of this,
at the API level.
So we will never build something
like a real application
on top of that.
It's just the API
level so that people
can build their own
interfaces or products
or whatever so that they
can connect it in however
they want.
GABI FERRARA: You mentioned that
everything-- it's API based.
And people create their
applications on top of it.
How does the work on the
perspective of developer
experience on that, because,
like, everything is on API?
And we know, like, APIs, if
they don't have documentation,
they don't help much.
You rely a lot on that.
And what helps developers
beyond your documentation
around tooling to help
work with Weaviate?
LAURA HAM: Yeah,
so documentation
is a great thing and also a
really big thing to work on,
I would say.
I'm currently writing it.
But in our documentation, we
have really straightforward
examples, which
you could directly
try out in your own
Weaviate cluster
if you signed up for
one at our website.
And then, we make the API as
straightforward as possible.
So we have the API--
there's a RESTful API.
And if you want to populate
or fill the database--
you use RESTful API calls.
So all these are
listed on our website
and explain how you can post
data and update some data.
And if you want to
query the data--
so either get something you're
specifically looking for
or explore the
data, because you're
looking for something you
don't know about or looking
for new relations-- then you're
doing this all via the GraphQL
API, which is designed from
a more human perspective.
So it's based on
natural language.
And all of this is, of course,
also documented with examples.
GABI FERRARA: How do
you deal with questions
that comes from the developers?
You mentioned that you do a lot
of open source communities--
so Meetups, conferences,
probably Stack Overflow, Slack.
But when you deal
with Enterprise,
what is your channel to help
them achieve their goals?
LAURA HAM: Yeah,
so for enterprises,
which are usually
big businesses,
we have solution engineers.
And these solution engineers
can help you from the start.
So they can help you
defining use cases
and then building an
ontology together,
because as also Jon mentioned--
[LAUGHTER]
--not everyone knows what an
ontology is from the beginning.
We really help you with that.
And then, also, setting
up the whole environment--
we can provide help with that.
And if they have
any questions, they
can always come back to
the solution engineers.
So right now, it's
really flexible.
We have no set way of
working in terms of,
we do this and this
and not this and this.
But we are really flexible in
contact with our customers.
JON FOUST: Awesome.
It seems like for each
customer, there's,
like, a dedicated solution
engineer that you can rely on.
LAURA HAM: As a
Enterprise, you can always
rely on one solution
engineer, which
is always available for you.
Yes.
JON FOUST: Is there
anything that we missed
or you know, anything that
you would like to mention
before we wrap things up?
Possibly where can we see
Weaviate in the future?
Like, will you be
at any conferences?
Will you be at any Meetups?
Are there going to be
any new online content
that you're going to
be posting pretty soon?
LAURA HAM: So we are soon
releasing our new website
with new documentation,
because we also
released a new version
of Weaviate itself.
This will be by the release of
this podcast already online.
By the end of
October, we will have
Meetups organized in Amsterdam,
New York, and San Francisco.
The dates are not set yet.
But we can communicate this
via newsletters or our website.
JON FOUST: Awesome.
And we'll also post those
dates if we get them
before this episode airs.
It's been a pleasure
having you, Laura.
It's been amazing.
When you come to New
York, make sure you,
you know, give me
and Gabi a ring.
We can probably go out
for lunch or something.
[LAUGHS]
GABI FERRARA: Oh, yeah.
Yeah, and if we
go to Amsterdam--
[LAUGHS]
--we would like to let you know.
JON FOUST: Oh, yeah.
That's also a very good option.
LAURA HAM: Well, if you go to
Helsinki, also, because I'm
currently living in Helsinki.
[LAUGHS]
JON FOUST: So I guess we're
gaining business justification
to go to Helsinki, it seems.
[LAUGHTER]
LAURA HAM: Oh, yeah.
You're always welcome.
JON FOUST: Well,
thanks, again, Laura,
for joining us on this episode.
And thank you, Gabi,
for joining me, as well.
And we look forward to seeing
the great things that Weaviate
is going to produce.
GABI FERRARA: See
you later, Laura.
And come to New York, too.
LAURA HAM: Thanks
for inviting me.
[LAUGHS]
GABI FERRARA: Thank you,
Laura, for talking to us
about Weaviate and
knowledge graphs.
That was really insightful.
JON FOUST: Yeah, it
was pretty amazing.
And as you can tell
from this episode,
I was really
interested in ontology
and how it's being used to
build on knowledge graphs.
So it was very
insightful and very cool.
And I will probably end
up taking a big peek
at what they're doing.
So it's awesome.
GABI FERRARA: There are links
on the show notes for you
to see their repository and see
a bit more about their product.
JON FOUST: So Gabi, let's get
into our question of the week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So let's get into our question
of the week, which is when will
Python 2 reach end of life?
And what does it mean for GCP?
Gabi, hopefully you have
some insight on that.
GABI FERRARA: So from what
I could see on our GitHub
repository, our client
libraries already
are only guaranteed
to work on Python 3.
Like, for instance
on App Engine,
it's not working on Python 2.
We don't do that
guarantee anymore.
But officially, Python 2 end
of life is January 1, 2020.
So it's time to
look at your codes,
see if you are doing anything
with Python 2, and upgrade it,
because a lot of things changed.
And I see people going
havoc about that.
[LAUGHS]
So I recommend you
getting a look now.
And on GCP, that's the thing.
We are not going to
support Python 2 anymore.
So just take a look of the
client libraries, GitHub,
and see what you're using.
So you can upgrade your code.
JON FOUST: Awesome.
And I think you
mentioned to me earlier
that there's, like, a countdown
clock for it, as well.
GABI FERRARA: Oh, yeah, there
is this website that I found.
So a countdown clock--
so if you keep an eye when
the end of life is happening,
it's just a page.
But it's the link in there.
So take a look.
Put it on our Favorites
and like bookmarks.
And just keep a look on that.
JON FOUST: Right.
We'll include it
in the show notes.
And maybe someone, who's
really brave will, like,
design some external,
like, countdown clock,
like how they have
for New Year's.
And then, people,
who are, you know,
working with Python on GCP
or just Python in general
will be able to,
you know, monitor
as soon as the clock hits 12:00
for New Year's that Python 2
will no longer be supported.
So it would be kind of funny
to see someone actually
build it out.
GABI FERRARA: It kind
of reminds me of the--
remember when the clocks were
going to change, and like,
everybody was worried about
that it would not work?
But like, I think you
call the millennial bug?
[BUZZ]
AUTOMATED VOICE: The inevitable
approaching doom of Y2K.
JON FOUST: Yeah.
GABI FERRARA: So it's kind
of like that, I think.
JON FOUST: Gabi,
where are you going
to be in the upcoming months?
GABI FERRARA: Next
week, I actually
I'm going to Belgium
for Full Stack Europe.
I'm going to put a
link on the show notes.
So can check it out.
JON FOUST: That's awesome.
GABI FERRARA: You?
JON FOUST: For me,
my twin brother
is getting married this week.
So I'm going to be the
best man at the wedding.
I'm super excited.
I know that they're excited.
And I just can't
wait to be surrounded
by friends and family to, you
know, celebrate this moment.
Outside of that
personal thing, I
will be going to
KubeCon in November.
So if you're going to be
there, be sure to stop by.
And you know, we're
running our workshop
on Open Match, which is
our matchmaking framework.
Feel free to stop by if
you want to get interested
in open source project
for games and you know,
connecting millions and
millions of players together.
GABI FERRARA: Cool.
And good luck on the wedding.
[LAUGHS]
JON FOUST: Thank you.
GABI FERRARA: Have fun.
[LAUGHS]
JON FOUST: Definitely
will-- well,
Gabi, it's been a pleasure.
And we want to thank all
our listeners for listening
and we will see
you all next week.
GABI FERRARA: See
I hope so.
[LAUGHS]
[MUSIC PLAYING]